these are going to be earlier companies
we think year five six seven
is the is the window for these which is
what it used to be
right i mean yeah i mean what happened
in the 90s
well the 90s has actually lasted reduced
to like three four five which may be a
little fast
5 million 10 million in revenue yeah
that might be a little bit the low end
but
somewhere between four and seven feels
pretty good for a high growth company
that has predictability
and it has medium scale to me medium
scale is like somewhere between
35 40 50 million in revenue with
predictability where you can talk
in an educated and accurate way about
the likely revenues
one two three four quarters out then you
should be a public company for the most
part
but they don't have to be correct me if
i'm wrong here
uh absolutely certain and robust with 10
billion in revenue like an airbnb or an
uber
or you know something where you know
you've got this massive footprint
so that people can have an opportunity
to have their public shares accelerate
when people bought uber
or when they buy airbnb some of these
companies are very
fully richly valued and there's not
as much growth available to those retail
investors
well just speaking i mean that's both
true and false i mean like for example
if you had bought shopify in the public
market you'd be very happy with your
returns
if you bought if you'd bought tesla in
the public markets basically anywhere
along the way you'd be
phenomenally satisfied with your returns
if you'd bought my old company paypal in
the public markets oh
um well even
even like recently like i i to show you
how much i haven't touched my linkedin
profile
on my linkedin profile it's sites like
paypal being worth 40 billion
it's only worth like 6x that but it's
the last time i edited my linkedin
profile
so um you know so like there's lots of
opportunities for growth potential
in the public markets um so i don't know
if that's a real reason
to prefer a spec um i think some of the
other reasons are
much more structural and fundamental
especially from a founder's perspective
when you have uh when you lower the bar
of entry you make it more fluid to go
public you also get let's face it
some people maybe who shouldn't be
running companies are going public
putting products out there we saw nikola
fisker basically anybody who does
anything that's in any way tangential to
what elon has done
is able to ride his coattails and say
we're going to be the next tesla
and you might have some product being
put out there that let's face it
these are not great companies or they're
massively speculative
how does the are you concerned the smack
space
you know for every chamath run or reed
hoffman and mark pincus run and and
people who are super qualified you might
have this like
kind of i don't know low quality
inventory maybe is a generous way to say
it
yeah sure but there's been low quality
inventory available in the public market
for a long time
um whether they're large market cap
mid-market cap or small market cap
companies
i don't know if that's new and i think
there'll be a flight to quality i think
it'll also be
a way of gauging the reputation i mean
one of the things you can do with this
back is the spac
sponsors are sort of endorsing a
specific valuation
whereas the old school investment
bankers
are really not doing anything truthfully
and so
it's not like if you take your company
public through goldman sachs and i'm not
picking on goldman sachs particularly
just about the quintessential investment
bank
they are not like really doing anything
they're not taking real risk they're not
putting their brand behind your
evaluation whereas the spax sponsor is
explicitly saying
in a memo form we believe open door is
worth
x here's why here's our logic here's our
investment logic
so i think there'll be um sort of a
sorting a reputation
sorting and ranking of spac sponsors
based upon both their historical
performance
of other things they've sponsored in the
public domain and then be the quality of
their work because their work is going
to be public their intellectual work is
going to be public for everybody to
consume and debate and critique